hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game uh from the final round
of the fide World rapid Championship
definitely deserves attention as uh so
many winning positions were reached in
this game and none of them were
exploited in the end of the game kind of
uh went uh the wrong way for one of the
players but the chances that we're not
taking this game uh will uh make a very
nice pause the video moment for you guys
we will have maybe even three pause the
video moments I'm gonna decide once I
start the video uh but uh I mean it's
very hard to imagine something like like
this happening between such such uh
immensely strong players and especially
uh as it was not made in time trouble uh
uh well especially one of the players
had well just a lot of time on the clock
so let's dive straight into it and then
we'll see what happens so Arjun uh Arjun
finished in fifth place in the world
rapid Championship with um uh some half
a point behind Fabiano caruana and
Vincent Kammer who had second and third
place okay Magnus was unreachable but
yeah fifth place definitely admirable I
think behind the dubov who was in fourth
uh uh so uh incredible placement but
still this game is really amazing let's
check it out Arjun with the white pieces
opens with Pawn to D4 we have Knight to
F6 Bishop to F4 going for a London setup
a D5 and now Pawn to E3 and here main
moves are C5 and E6 Bishop to F5 uh
somewhat a lesser played by the bishop
to G4 that mamidaro goes for is very
very rare it goes after the White Queen
and okay Arjun plays Queen to D3 and now
uh you might have to worry about some
Queen B5 check ideas losing the B7 Pawn
even though from practice you know that
this is never really an issue well
Madeira does go Queen to C8 and it is
now already as of move 4 that we have a
completely new game very very rare setup
for Black so okay C4 uh makes sense this
is the movie always want to play with
Ponto E6 Knight to C3 and now Bishop to
B4 pinning that Knight Knight to F3 and
now uh among they are just castles he
could mess up white spawn structure here
but this would only give white a very
strong Center while I give white the
semi-open G file and as mamidara wants
the castle King side not really
something you are even considering so
castles we have A3 now and the bishop
back to D6 supposing White's a very
strong dark Square Bishop Knight to E5
now attacking the bishop on G4 and
Bishop to F5 attacking the queen queen
goes back to the starting Square Queen
D1 and now D captures uh on C4 grabbing
that pawn and here instead of
recapturing that's a weird Arrow uh
Arjun could also consider just G for G5
he does have everything set up for that
but he goes to Bishop captures on C4
first and now Rook to d8 we have Queen
to E2 of course you want to get the
queen out of the D file and now Bishop
captures on E5 says I'm not interested
in any G4 ideas so let's just eliminate
one of the Defenders of the G4 Square D
captures an E5 and now we have Knight F
to D7 and here we have Knight the B uh
sorry a knight after D7 and here Arjun
just castles Queen side even though the
bishop to G5 definitely deserves
attention asking mommy there what is up
with that Rook on d8 but okay it's rapid
we have Queen side castles now comes
Knights to B6 attacking the bishop and
E4 now attacking the bishop on F5 Bishop
to G6 and now Bishop back to A2 not
allowing the trade to happen Knight the
C6 mamidar continues development and now
Bishop to G5 attacking The Rook forcing
the trade on D1 my video goes for this
Rook captures Rook captures and now Pawn
to H6 with Bishop to H4 and now shahider
plays um well not the first weird move
of the game but not the last one
definitely Knight captures and if 5 and
the question is what is up with Rook the
d8 check what is that is mamidarov just
offering a queen uh well it was not
played in the game but let's say Rook
the d8 check uh Arjun can win the queen
and he plays something like F3 he
defends D for Pawn mandarov has a rook
in the Knight for a queen definitely
does not sound like a compensation but
if you check out the game and there is a
actual uh footage of the game by chess
base India on their Channel you can
check it out will be the first link in
the description below it doesn't seem
like Arjun even gave this much thought
he just uh he spent like less than five
seconds on this move and he had a fair
amount of time on this Claw on his clock
Arjun had like three minutes here Mommy
Joe had almost four minutes on his clock
uh but okay yeah he just plays Ponte F4
he has a very clear idea of what he
wants to do Knight back the C6 and now
Pawn to G4 we have F6 by Shakira and now
comes Ponte E5 uh he wants the he wants
to play F5 but he wants the it up first
by playing Ponte E5 you could also
consider F5 and then E5 but this is a
bit more straightforward so F captures
an E5 and now Pawn to F5 making use of
the pin along this diagonal Dash up to
F7 and now Pawn to F6 this is how Arjun
breaks through mamidarov's defenses uh
G5 now attacking the bishop G6 was more
solid G5 allows Bishop captures on G5
but it was not played in the game
interestingly Bishop captures and G5 if
mamidaro was to recapture then Queen E3
and he can just resign but okay after G5
Bishop the G3 was played and now Knight
to D5 setting up a lot of traits here
Bishop captures on E5 and now Queen to
E8 preparing to bring the other Rook
into the game uh here uh Arjun had like
a minute on the clock manager had two
and a half minutes on the clock he plays
H4 now comes Rook to d8 and H captors on
G5 and if you were black here and you
had the option of trading pretty much
all of White's attackers here that's
exactly what you should do for example
Knight captures uh on E5 you could play
this and then after
um
uh sorry after a white played H captors
and G5 you will want to play Knight
captures on E5 and then after Queen
captures any five you want to trade on
C3 and then you want to trade on D1 and
the white is pretty much out of
attackers you can even play Queen A5
Queen A4 check and after King D2 pick up
the opponent G4 and defend the E6 Pawn
so you don't even have to worry about
that if captures an H6 just King H7 you
pick up the pawn nothing spectacular is
happening here but mamidaro decided to
play H captures on G5 which completely
changes the character of the position
and brings us to our first pause the
video moment what did mamidarov Miss
here feel free to pause the video and
try to find the winning move for uh
Arjun while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on realizing that
the open Age file is the the only path
to Victory and for those of you who just
won't enjoy the show it is Rook the H1
this is what mom made our missed and
Arjun plays it and now the problem is
you no longer have the option of just
trading everything let's say you try
what we attempted uh before now the G5
Pawn is hanging in the line that we've
shown the the Blackboard was on H6 and
there was a white Pawn on G5 but now
this is a a pretty big threat that would
just result in in a very quick Checkmate
so instead after Rook to H1 Bishop to G6
was played by shakaria and now again uh
this leaves black open to all sorts of
nasty ideas uh once again feel free to
pause the video and try to find the
winning idea for Arjun uh while I give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting either of
the two winning ideas uh one being
Bishop to B1 but that's uh we don't even
have to go for that the pretty
straightforward one is The Rook to h8
check so congratulations to anyone who
spotted that as it was missed by Arjuna
in the game point is that if the black
king moves you just win the black queen
and if you capture then look at this F7
check and that's pretty much it uh if
Knight captures an E5 you just capture
with the queen again delivered check
King H7 now you pick up the queen and
after Rook captures uh you have all the
compensation in the world I mean it's
not even compensation it's uh you
haven't even given up anything for that
Queen let's say Bishop captures Queen
captures with check you have a queen for
a rook that's completely winning but
okay after this bishop the G6 move Arjun
does not find Rook to h8 instead Arjun
goes for Queen to H2 he wants the
checkmate mamiderev with some sort of
queen h8 queen to G7 maneuvering but now
King the F7 by shark and now Queen to H6
going for Queen to G7 Checkmate and what
mamajarov should do here is Queen to G8
but it's very hard to see why he plays
Queen to f8 which stops Checkmate but it
allows a very very nasty idea from White
so once again for the third time feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for Arjun uh while I give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on always looking for
a sneaky way to sacrifice your queen and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show look at this queen captures on
G6 check it was not played in the game
but if it was it would be a spectacle to
behold because now uh King characters on
G6 is the only move and now Bishop to B1
with check and now look at the monster
Bishop pair from Hell King F7 rooked the
H7 with check King the E8 Bishop to G6
with check and you are out of moves with
your king you have to give up your queen
now Bishop captures an F7 checking to D7
and it seems like okay maybe black can
defend this but not really pretty much
anything is winning just Bishop H5 check
you can force the king in the corner
Knight captures on D5 all sorts of
threats against the C7 Pawn if you
capture an E5 then let's say a 97 check
into B8 F7 and white is down a full
Bishop a black is down a full Bishop of
course there is no defending there's the
past Pawn uh will will be too much to at
the handle so uh that was also in the
position but after Queen fate uh Arjun
misses this he plays uh Queen captures
on G5 and now Mommy there of all he has
to do is capture the bishop and there is
no winning uh uh ideas here for for
Arjun let's say captures captures Queen
to C5 now and uh nothing really
happening here there's no Rook to H7 the
bishop is now a very good Defender also
keeps the the white king for from
escaping in the corner uh not uh easy to
deal with this but he played Queen to C5
right away and now finally there is only
one winning move for Arjun here and this
time he spots it he plays Rook to H7
check and it was in this position on
move 33 that Shakira mamidar resigned
the game and with this Victory uh Arjun
irrigation finishes fifth in the world
rapid Championship the problem is now if
you capture The Rook now Queen gains
access to G7 King 8 F7 check and and
then well you just get to Queens into
the game this also comes with checking
C8 Queen captures and C5 uh you have two
queens and if you don't uh capture The
Rook it's not much better King to f8 you
just play Queen to H7 with a H6 with
checking it you capture and G6 with
check King to f8 and now any Checkmate
will do queen F7 Rook to h8 everything
is Checkmate uh but really a remarkable
game that uh is sort of uh unexplainable
I mean uh uh uh starting with with this
idea there were weirder moves even uh
before this position was reached but
here Mommy they're just cold-bloodedly
plays Knight captures on E5 and I mean
I'm pretty sure that he did not see
queen or Rook the d8 check and neither
did neither did Arjun because you just
don't see it in the rise when they're
playing the game I urge you to check out
the video is the first link in the
description below it's just uh
impossible to explain but not only was
dismissed I I guess maybe because it was
the final round Okay the third day of
the rapid everyone is tired Maybe Mommy
are of not even
motivated to play uh but I I I I even
without that it's impossible to miss
like all of this uh so yeah uh really
wild stuff uh hope you guys hope you
guys enjoyed it and uh you know keep
suggesting Wild games from the from the
world rapid and Blitz as there were so
many of them being played uh I'm sure we
are going to discover many more gems uh
so yeah that's the game once again hope
you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank Ben Benjamin Aaron kumara rabbit
seven Yoon Young and the mittens for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of uh you know Wild games that
we've missed and checking up on your
wonderful suggestions
um as I usually do so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day